the explosion left a crater around three
meters deep
flats in the surrounding residential
apartment blocks were destroyed
the blast shredded trees in the park
where children usually play
this was one of a number of attacks
across krematorsk in what was the
largest simultaneous barrage of rockets
on the city
since russia invaded ukraine more than
two months ago
we were sleeping and were awoken by a
series of explosions before there was
one massive blast thank god no one was
killed
a couple of kilometers away this parade
of shops and small businesses was also
hit
the city mayor says that 25 people were
injured in the attacks it's miraculous
that nobody was killed
soldiers have collected shrapnel to try
and identify the weapon that was used
i heard it was a rocket attack there was
a siren and then a huge explosion my
apartment is about 100 meters from here
and all the windows were blown out
the scale of the destruction here shows
you just how powerful the explosion
was there are tens of flats that have
been pretty much completely destroyed in
the blast
the ukrainian police say that they
believe that this was a russian air
strike and it comes in a time when the
ukrainian army say that russian forces
are trying to push in towards
kramertorsk and neighbouring cervansk
from the north
we drove north towards the
russian-controlled city of isiam
discarded blood-soaked bandages and a
stretcher
a wounded ukrainian soldier had been
transferred to an ambulance here only
minutes before
australia
cars are being shelled when our cars go
along the road they start shelling it
they shoot any vehicle ambulances
civilian vehicles it doesn't matter
ukrainian soldiers hide in the forest
from russian drones above
artillery shell casings litter the
ground
the soldiers won't let us film them but
they claim they have repelled three
waves of russian attacks in the last
week
they give us this video they claim shows
them retreating from russian artillery
fire
they say they are now holding their
defensive position
but what they currently can't do is stop
cities like kramatorsk from coming under
russian attacks
channel stratfor al jazeera krematorsk